through the aftermath of battle in what
used to be a marketplace now a munition
shells lit to the streets the situation
remains dire for Sudanese trapped inside
a city-turned Battleground
crisis is Big the situation is very
tough and there's difficulty in internal
movements we often stand in long queues
to get bread it happened many times
where we get bread but never the amount
that my family need
the damage has hit everything both of
them are fighting each other and we the
people will be the biggest losers and
the most affected
where's the two parties to the conflict
namely al-burhan and hamiti to show the
Sudanese people 10 percent only of the
care and attention they gave to foreign
countries through safe corridors to
evacuate their Nationals from the
country we need to take our sick people
to hospitals and to remove the dead
bodies from the streets
Emergency Services have been stretched
Beyond capacity and are pleading for
help a doctor filmed these scenes at the
Khartoum Hospital
there are still injured people in the
hospital medical supplies are very
scarce no medical teams have managed to
reach us due to lack of security and
safety on the roads leading to the
hospital the injured are still coming to
hospital because of the current battles
if the fighting wasn't enough some
fear-armed looters even more CCTV
footage captures men dressed in military
fatigues and carrying weapons breaking
into shops it's not clear who these men
are or which side they belong to both
the Army and Rapid support forces accuse
each other of breaching Law and Order
elsewhere in the country the town jinena
near the border with Chad has seen
intense battles
the area has witnessed ethnic conflict
in the recent past now the sound of
gunfire can be heard as locals run for
cover
their reports the city has no
electricity and very limited phone
connectivity concerns over return to
Civil War are high for many in Darfur
the previous War lasted nearly 20 years
and pitted Arab tribes against ethnic
darfuries the fighting in recent days
has again highlighted that division
countries continue to evacuate their
people from Sudan Aid workers arrived in
Jordan on Thursday I think all of us
feel very relieved but all of us are
have very mixed feelings also because we
live our Sudanese people behind
the Sudanese Army has denied reports it
will enter into direct talks with the
rsf Sudan's foreign Ministry said in a
statement the rapid support forces have
no choice but to surrender or perish
Heber Morgan Al Jazeera Khartoum